[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with daily mirror
economist susie boniface and assistant
comment editor the daily telegraph
madeline grant they'll be with us from
now until just before midnight
putin closes in on kiev is the headline
in the eye which says russian forces are
systematically targeting anyone who
tries to leave the city or find food
leaving streets littered with dead
bodies
while the times reporter inside the
capital says people there are ready to
face the onslaught
the front of the mirror is dominated by
an image of the ukrainian mum-to-be who
was injured in the attack on the
maternity hospital in mariopol with her
new baby girl
that image is also on the front of the
guardian which leads with the french
president emmanuel macron's criticism of
the uk's treatment of ukrainian refugees
the financial times reports that g7
countries have ended all normal trade
relations with russia to punish it as
hard as possible economically for the
invasion
former cabinet minister jeremy hunt
tells the telegraph britain should
increase defense spending to the same
level as the united states
the daily express says ukrainian spy
chiefs believe president putin is
plotting a terror attack on chernobyl
and will blame it on ukraine to hold the
world to ransom
not now north korea and india is the
star's headlines as kim jong-un tests a
new rocket that can hit america and
india accidentally fires a missile at
pakistan
the son claims prince harry has snubbed
the royal family by refusing to fly home
for his grandfather prince phillips
memorial service
while the mail leads on the news that
the queen will no longer take part in
monday's commonwealth day service
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by daily mirror
columnist susie boniface and assistant
comment editor of the daily telegraph
madeline grant welcome to both of you i
think you'll have to do the majority of
the talking my voice is uh increasingly
leaving me uh let's start with the um
eye and the front page there the
headline that uh vladimir putin is
closing in on kiev and all the
intelligence suggests that that is his
his target susie
yes so you know this is something
we're entering the third week of the war
now
keeve should have been if if everything
was was going according to to the
russian plan should have been taken in
the first couple of days
the opposition should have just crumbled
whatever there was and the people of
ukraine should have welcomed him and his
troops with open arms there's been a
40-mile convoy of tanks uh verging on
kiev for the past fortnight uh being
attacked and getting stuck running out
of fuel and the cavalry has basically
had to dismount and it's now dispersed
it's headed into the trees and the mud
around kiev
and they're moving howitzers into place
now howitzers for those who that may not
know
are long-range artillery and they don't
give you direct line of sight they're
indirect fire okay so if the soldiers
who are using them just do a calculation
according to information they're given
at the other end they've got some kind
of spotter in key who'll tell them where
to point the guns and the point of that
is that you can be a long way away from
the thing that you're hitting you don't
see the people that you're killing
and you have also very little idea as to
what it is you're targeting you're
relying on the information you're being
given and this is the opposite
of what this war was supposed to be and
it is the opposite of what happens in a
war where you're winning this what
happens when you are losing this kind of
thing when you want to remove your
soldiers from the things that we don't
want them to see what they're doing you
don't want them to be part of it you
can't go face to face with the
ukrainians because they're going to
fight you
um and you have to move in long-range
artillery because you just can't get
close enough
this is a it's going to be
brutal when it happens
but it is a it is a sign of failure on
putin's part and that's where we are
yeah certainly the analysis that's been
been coming through in in coming days is
that not necessarily that that he's
losing but he doesn't have the the upper
hand because he's on the the back foot
as it were he wasn't expecting to meet
the resistance that that he has done so
far madeline
yes that's absolutely right and it does
come from a place of weakness but in a
way paradoxically that weakness means
that all bets are off um you see
signs of that weakness all the time the
fact that they're the russian forces are
having to get chechnyan um mercenaries
involved and people from syria to fight
for them the fact that commanders quite
high ranking commanders are being killed
all of this very much as susie pointed
out so brilliantly suggests that things
are not going to plan but it also means
that when things are not going to plan
they may resort to
much more brutal and aggressive tactics
that they might otherwise not have
needed to deploy howard says a really
good example um but there's also you
know the ongoing worries about chemical
weapons these are the kind of things
that you do
as happen in syria when breaking a
conventional siege doesn't work using
the conventional means so you have to
resort to these absolutely barbaric and
inhumane
atrocities so the fear is that having
been pushed into a weakened position um
having been cornered in that sense that
um what will come from russia next is
you know breaking all of the usual rules
of war perhaps even more than they
already have been breaking them
and time and time again we've heard of
the the spirit of the uh the people of
ukraine ready to to fight
for their land and the times uh saying
that they they're ready for the
onslaught they're expecting it and
they're prepared
yeah they seem to have been you know
they've been using they've had plenty of
warning shall we say the whole world has
this is what's going to happen
and they've used that time to fortify
the city to get art treasures safely
away and and hidden underground
they've been building tank traps and
stingers and things that can stop
vehicles and shred tyres they've been
preparing um and
any kind of urban warfare with an
invading force and people protecting
their homes
is really
messy and unpleasant um and
you will kill
five times
as
i can't remember the ratio now the ratio
is five to one and i'm pretty certain
someone will correct me i'm sure on
twitter if i've got it wrong i'm pretty
certain that you will lose five soldiers
for every one civilian that you have to
kill in this other way round but it's
basically it's it's a unsuccessful
unhappy thing for anyone to be trying to
do to take over a city and especially
when they have had so much warning and
so much time to prepare um the ukrainian
defenses have surprised everybody
they've surprised the west who provided
a lot of those defensive
things but you know what they really
need and where they they do seem to be
um having a
wants that isn't being filled perhaps is
to have enough body armor helmets
ration packs medical packs they're the
things that they're gonna need in the
next stage of this war as they start
going
more in close fighting hand-to-hand
combat with the russians who are going
to start taking the city
uh one building at a time yes and
speaking to the fact that russia doesn't
have the the upper hand and they are um
on the back foot
moving further into the times they're
speaking of the the third major general
uh that russia has has lost as the army
advances on on cities there madeleine
yes exactly um and this is one of a
number of high-ranking soldiers to have
been killed and it suggests well firstly
that the ukrainians have been placing a
high priority in on going for the
russian command and control and they've
had some real success
um on that but it's it's also
significant that
such high-ranking officers are to be
found on the front line in the first
place it is perhaps a measure of how
morale is weakening that they have to be
there to urge urge their troops on and
just how badly the russian attack has
has gone compared to their um hopes and
expectations of um of a speedy takeover
of ukraine
the let's move on to the uh mirror
excuse me and um their headline their
hope amid horror and they've got
photographed the mum-to-be that we all
saw pictures of that was injured coming
out of that maternal hospital
she's now had her her baby daughter
yes i should say i need to correct
myself i did get it slightly wrong in
urban warfare you need to have five
attackers to one defender in order to
take a city
and the russians don't have the numbers
so i'm sorry if i've slightly muffed it
up when i was trying to explain it
earlier on but yes this front page is a
great picture of mariana the beauty
blogger who was pictured in the sort of
the wreckage of the
maternity hospital after it was bombed
and who was accused by the kremlin and
by the russian embassy in the uk who um
were absolutely disgraceful and so
because she was a blogger therefore she
must be acting and they said that the
blood on her face was makeup um
it's quite genuine that she was pregnant
uh she's now got scabs on her face fresh
ones as can be seen in that photograph
and but luckily she's had a healthy baby
girl veronica and one can only hope that
she has
um
a better outcome than most babies born
in moore because she certainly deserves
it and i would hope that whoever
operates the russian embassy twitter
account
is keeping their mouth shut about it
tonight
um yeah madeline to think that we were
told that this is was fake news
it's unbelievable it's the it's a level
of of well people call it
disinformation but i feel that that's
that's kind of too weak for the the
sickening tactics that are being used
where you you drop a bomb onto a heavily
pregnant woman and a maternity ward and
then add insult to injury by accusing
her of faking her own injuries it's kind
of like gaslighting on an industrial
scale um and you know it's nice to see
these these stories of hope amid the
rubble but
i can't help but be you know just
utterly sickened by the kind of tactics
that have been used on a regular basis
susie the express uh takes us into a
story about um
a plot a terror attack on chernobyl um
that putin is allegedly going to to
blame on ukraine
yeah now so chernobyl which had a
meltdown in 1986
is basically now it's kind of got a dome
over the top of it in which humans
aren't really allowed to go um robots go
in there instead because it's still
highly radioactive and ukraine has also
buried other radioactive wastes there
from decommissioned reactors from soviet
era so it's a it's a it's a very
radioactive sort of place
um and as we all know uh you know that
there have been troops firing near
nuclear power stations elsewhere in
ukraine
and
the russian troops took over the area
where chernobyl is at the start of the
conflict at the start of the war
and it's very easy when you have
something like that to create a big
accident and we already know that the
power has been cut to chernobyl um the
power is how you keep pumps working it's
how you keep things cooled down it's how
you keep things ventilated it's how you
keep the robots working and doing the
decommissioning work and so on and so
forth the ukrainian engineers in there
have been seem to have been ejected or
been lost contact with belarusian
engineers have gone in
uh and now there is a suggestion that
what's being done in there by the
foreign engineers who've come in is not
keeping chernobyl safe but is in fact
preparing some kind of accident in quote
marks which will you know when when
putin has to inevitably as it looks now
find a way out of this
or retreat um sort of cause some kind of
a horrible uh leak of radiation on his
way out the door
uh madden just very quickly we've just
got time for the express uh back pages
and the story of chelsea players being
worried and concerned uncertain about
the the future of the club following on
from roman abramovich being included on
on that uh list of those to be
sanctioned
yes absolutely now it seems as though
many insiders are saying that chelsea's
barclaycard credits cards have actually
been suspended meaning that they've been
left scrambling around wondering if they
can afford to keep playing um in spite
of the sanctions that have been imposed
on them and um with the their home game
against newcastle happening this weekend
and it's just it's strikes me that this
is a kind of um i guess a micro version
of what we're seeing across so many
areas of politics and the economy at the
moment that we're sort of horribly
exposed to this crisis in all sorts of
ways whether it's defense or food supply
or energy supply and with football we're
seeing that you can have a football club
that is essentially owned
by one person which means that there are
only you know one decision away from a
catastrophe if you suddenly find that
the ownership can no longer subsidize um
the club and putting even a club that
seemed to be you know such a kind of
cultural icon as chelsea football club
i'm now wondering if it can afford to
you know bust its players in and play
for the shirts and afford to host its
home games
susie you were shaking your head there